the jogan experience I admire people
like you that no no alcohol no weed no
nothing just discipline I admire that it
it just it builds us to be a little
stronger you know cuz man I done been
through so much [__] in life and watched
a lot of people go through stuff stuff
that make them may take their life cuz
it may be real crucial but when you get
to getting to the point of where I am
you deal with everything he up it's like
it ain't really much
it ain't like it's a breeze or a
cakewalk every time but for the most
part we'd be like man it'll be all right
I'll deal with it and you know that's
what keep me going well I guess also if
you get used to just dealing with [__]
then you get strong at dealing with [__]
whereas if you're just drowning it out
all the time then that becomes a habit
but it it's so crazy it's a it became
even a bigger habit for me right uh I
don't know how long ago it was when I
got shot but when I got shot they ended
up um
they actually the crazy thing is they
never they didn't do surgery or anything
right I got shot it was so many people
outside the hospital that they were like
man we need to get him out of here cuz
they they never seen nothing like that
so they don't know if the people outside
was against me or was for me they just
never seen it so um long story short um
left got
[Music]
home cleaned around and just got the
bleed and and stop but um days later
they tried to prescribe me medicine I
think I took the medicine probably for
the first five 6 days and then once I
decided that I could make it through
half a day without it I just like man
[__] it I'm just it can't get no worse
than this you know what I'm saying it
only get better
so dealing with that that's just it it
be it developed a habit of anything I do
I just go at it about that way I don't
know if you ever seen on on the on
YouTube I took the bullet out myself
Jesus yeah yeah but it's just where' you
get shot I got shot directly in my back
and um it shattered my shoulder blade
and spent to my uh shoulder so it sat
there for like four or five years and
it's so crazy right when you you hear
people tell you the story it is yeah so
that's me taking it out so it was
pushing out how long after you got shot
yeah about five could have been like
five years five years so the Bullet was
still it was working its way out of your
skin for years wow dude that's
crazy and went on and continue my
day did you get it stitched up at least
no really yeah but it it it h like it
was supposed to man I what the fact that
him not doing surgery on me when I got
shot and it healed I that was a cakewalk
at that point so why didn't they want to
do
surgery one I I don't know if for them
not have I guess for how many people was
there so fast and then them not being
able to go in and know if it's somewhere
that was damaging or or however you want
to put the words but um that [__] they
were like man we got to get them up out
of here and that was just the reality of
it but the only bad thing is cuz they
didn't move it and it was there it got
tangled up in a lot of my um nerves and
muscle so like if you ever pay attention
to me like I can't lift my arm directly
straight up or do a lot of different
things cuz it was sitting in there for
so many
years that's got to piss you off cuz
they could have just pulled that out
right could definitely yeah definitely
cuz it was it was so close to the edge
cuz from the time I got shot till the
time it came out you could always feel
it so it was that close that's the thing
about doctors like you get a really good
doctor or you can get a doctor it's like
[__] leave it in there and it's and
it's crazy right man cuz you I help a
lot of kids in life and you watch some
of these doctors they take a a personal
liking and loving to these kids and you
know just trying to figure out ways to
help them or even some of the elders and
then you got some people like [__] ah it
ain't going to work they ain't going to
make it you know what I'm saying that's
the [__] up part about it yeah well I
think some people get real calloused
unfortunately I see a lot of people die
and then they lose their feeling for it
and other people never do that's the the
best thing about great doctors is you
just really appreciate them if someone
who really cares you really appreciate
them that that
extra that
extra let's try one more time sometimes
can change everything as opposed that
there's nothing else we can do yeah
especially when someone's got a bullet
in their
shoulder get it out of there man
especially was right there like how far
below the surface was it like when you
first went in uh no so when I first went
in it was
literally it was just bulging like um if
you do it yeah so if you do this you
could always always feel it so though
like when you look at the video that was
on YouTube by that point it broke the
skin on his own cuz you know you'll hear
stories like bullets going they'll push
their way out or either yeah you'll hear
the stories of during rain or cold
weather it'll make you feel some way
like that [__] really for
real